one of the stars of Grace and Frankie on
Netflix Brooklyn Decker good to see you
good to see you it's my first time with
you here yes here yeah good to see you
good to see you again yeah absolutely
we've been we've been you're just too
busy we haven't seen each other in so
many years you are too busy acting with
Jane Fonda and Martin Sheen and Sam
Waterston and Lily Tomlin I mean you're
slumming life is good life is good I am
the lowest on the totem pole star any
good totem pole to be on yeah stop it no
it's true it's true do you look around I
mean honestly because sometimes you know
when I when I'm at work you know and I
it's my job to you know obviously place
people on the fly on the wall I do
sometimes stop and realize you know some
people would love to be right now here a
deal on and and Michael Irvin or
whatever did you ever stop there and
think that absolutely yeah and I mean
you know how it is like you're you're
supposed to be sort of you know these
are your these are your contemporaries
you all work together
right they're your colleagues you're
supposed to kind of be aboveboard like
I'm cool this doesn't bother me at all
we've worked together for years and to
this day I still get starstruck when I'm
on set I'm so quiet and I just watch
everything that they do I mean there's I
don't I think you know I grew up in
North Carolina where like you don't see
famous people like Larry sprinkle is our
weatherman and he was the most famous
person I think he's still the weatherman
in North Carolina behind the weather
man's name is Larry sprinkle does it
come out I think it's real is that a
given I think this I hope it is let's
just say it is we have Dallas Raines out
here right he's a guy with he's not know
he's here oh that's a shame that's an
opportunity missed he isn't all but I do
believe he's got the Hall of Fame fake
bake George Hamilton I'm envious my
winter skin is very envious so Larry
sprinkle sprinkle was the biggest
celebrity I'd ever met and so then to be
on set with you know Jane Fonda and
Martin Sheen and Sam Waterston Lily
Tomlin it's very humbling every day plus
Martin she's the President of the United
States it's one of my favorite years of
all time we studied it in politics in
high school we would study episodes of
The West Wing so to work with him I get
to call him dad it's wild man I I would
love to have been in that class isn't
that cool
so
you you're taking politics yeah and the
teachers like let's watch the West Wing
yes yes yes
well I took politics it was my senior
year of high school and it was during an
election year it was Kerry Bush and so
during an election you're taking a
politics class watching The West Wing it
doesn't really get much better than that
and so as a seventeen eighteen year old
I was completely just mystified by
politics and policy and that was thanks
to my awesome teacher like how cool is
that you're writing a paper on Rob Lowe
I mean so much and talk about a nice tan
you know a 17 year old that's a pretty
fun thing to watch Brooklyn Decker here
on the Rich Eisen show okay so you're
from Ohio right original born in Ohio
you're catering outside of middle so do
you have any Todd do you consider
yourself an Ohio North Carolinian North
Carolina that's where I was raised but I
still have a lot of family Middletown
Ohio so we go back love to visit but
yeah North Carolina okay so that's why
you would you became a Panther fan once
they came into being yes so I was in the
fourth grade when the franchise started
in North Carolina so that's why I'm a
Panther fan okay yeah
so what do you think of the current
state of your your team I mean I'm
really excited about next year obviously
I'm bummed and was hoping we could go
further but I'm really excited about
next year we saw the team a few years
ago they're incredible they're
incredible defense
right we had Olson out for most of the
season I love that guy by the way that
guy is one of my favorite people he just
seems like a good guy yes do you know
him I do that's exciting I do and he's
got a great career in sports
broadcasting should you so choose he's a
good dude
yeah he's great in the community he's
definitely out there's a lot for
Charlotte yeah well now horner minute
more more for Charlotte than Larry
sprinkle or less that's a tough call I'm
a Larry sprinkle sprinkle oilless it was
really hard I don't mean to put you on
the spot causing riots in the streets of
Charlotte and unfortunately with this
debate but no I mean Greg Olson he's
just I mean we have so many guys like
that on the team I'm a huge Cam Newton
fan I know he's controversial I'm a huge
cam fan Kuechly like you have a lot of
really great men on that team Brian
Khalil also yeah one of our favorites
here on this show when he comes on here
he and my husband have like a Twitter
bromance going on right now they're
following each other they message each
other okay now
let's delve into this a little bit I
don't know much about it I'm kept in the
dark to be honest what do you mean like
a concern like a DM situation direct
messaging on Twitter it might mean
something else I don't know about okay
DM al-khalil and Randy Roddick or going
back and forth apparently did you just
call Andy Roddick did I I feel like
that's fitting did I recheck the tomaybe
Andy Roddick DMing Khalil really putting
something out there we'd be breaking
news right really maybe I mixed up
Ryan's name with Andy's yeah but okay if
there were a couple Randy erotic there
you go
Randi Korell Colorado
we're workshopping and it's a huge fan
of all of them yeah so okay they they
almost took care of business against the
Saints how much have you been thanks
Graham go no I know no I'm saying no no
he liked the first I think nine point to
the game were thanks to Graham good no
I'm serious like we didn't have a point
on the board short kicker
I get very when when when kickers get
mentioned
I'm very kiddin mean to get defensive no
I'm giving him props like he actually
put points on the board for the first
right like the I mean the first nine
points of the game were all thanks to
Graham Cano I think in that game yes he
did yeah the Saints were keeping him out
of the yeah exactly
sometimes you have to depend on the
kicking game hey I'm a Gogan oh okay
Goggan oh by the way I'm gonna I'm gonna
trademark that would you please get that
again Brooklyn Decker here on the Rich
Eisen show tell me about finery tell me
about what you're doing with Whitney
Casey right yes former anchor of CNN
yeah what are you doing
so we started a website called finery
that's basically an operating system for
your wardrobe so if you've seen clueless
I don't know if you've seen clueless the
closet right the clueless closet which
is every person's dream especially every
woman's dream we've actually created and
we just finished around a funding which
is very hard for females and technology
we just closed at Christmas and it was
announced on Tuesday okay so we launched
a website a year ago and our app just
came out finery dot-com go check it out
but basically what iTunes did for your
music when you thought about like action
transitioning from CDs to a digitized
music collection we're doing that for
your wardrobe interesting yeah so just
to again explain it to me so your your
you're now what able to order something
yes so you order something online it's
primarily for online shoppers you order
something online and it's automatically
put into your wardrobe and so the
convenience of that is like think about
packing you don't have to actually spend
time in your closet when you think about
you have your music your banking your
travel it's all mobile yes and the one
thing we don't really have mobile is our
closet right our physical belongings you
think about how much time is actually
spent in your closet getting dressed
it's so hours a week so you you input
into something digital it for you it's
all fully automated you sign up with
your email and we do it all for you boy
you guys would be so embarrassed
just to see listed in black and white
what's in your guy's closets I'm sure
could we so let's just say this okay
York lot not of just a closet what about
somebody's under the desk area no he has
an issue well not anymore because I had
to consolidate it might look like if if
this needed to be some sort of shelter
he's good
really oh yeah what do you have well
there we go
Chris Brockman peeps my mom sent me like
two years ago hmm that's like Easter
2015 yeah okay would you eat one right
now yeah I mean I think they're good for
like 15 or 20 years just offered I offer
to eat when I don't want to eat well
this is neat this is great great so your
so there's no there's nothing fine or
finery about that at all you have about
eight dress shirts and two pairs of
pants and a bunch of hats fold it
underneath the just in case you know
just life happens or like if you get one
of the alerts they got in Hawaii you'd
be ready to go to hunker down you'd be
like a stander you'd be shoving us out
of the way going out at Brooklyn Decker
on Twitter grace in Frankie season 4
premieres on Netflix starting tomorrow
when we come back for the television
audience we're gonna see a clip of that
and then we come back I do want to talk
about your dogs okay and what they are
named one after an all-time tennis great
not named Andy Roddick correct and one
after an all time sports broadcast and
great yep not named Richard why you
don't want to say that cuz that means
I'm calling myself a broadcasting grade
you are a broadcasting great but let
someone else say it for you right like
isn't that let us wait for you my dog is
not named rich rice okay that's next
year on the Rich Eisen show
another segment here at Brooklyn Decker
again Grace and Frankie season 4
premieres on Netflix tomorrow
starring in part Brooklyn Decker so you
have two dogs two dogs yes okay Billie
Jean and Bob Costas okay now let's walk
let's talk about one dog is named Billie
Jean King after Billie Jean King yes and
the other dog is named Bob costis okay
laughter okay after Bob constable you
would assume yeah to be totally honest
with you we thought about rich but rich
Roddick it just was mercy okay like I
just couldn't name can I say that word
to say it if it's if it's appropriately
applied you're correct rich Roddick we
can't name a dog rich Roger all right
where did Bob costis come from to be
totally honest with you we so I grew up
with all rescue dogs we were touching
about that and coincidentally they all
had be names when we adopted them and so
when Andy and I got our first dog we
wanted to give her a B name and so of
course we were huge fans of Billy gene
and Andy adores her knows her personally
so we named our dog naturally after
Billy gene when we got our second dog we
just loved Billy and Bob but the idea of
two dogs being Billy and Bob and so we
tried to think of like a tennis Bob you
know and we thought of an Olympics Bob
Bob Costas and I don't Andy might know
Bob we've never met bob costas and i
have never met but he does know that our
dog is named after him
well you've never met Bob no I have not
okay is the actual real live Bob Costas
on the line here on the Rich Eisen
yes he is Bob yes and I'm just calling
to check on my name's eggy hello
Brooklyn but really I'm more concerned
with how my namesake is doing hi Bob
Costas I've never spoken before no no we
haven't and somehow you've managed I'm
sure to house-train
and take care of Bob Costas and the
canine Bob Costas is driving I trust
this good days and his bad days how
strained is generous you know he
occasionally leaves us a present on the
couch I hope you don't do the same and
he just got out of his con last week so
no we are not doing a great job raising
our bob costas but but
is a wonderful lovely fellow I'm sure
much like yourself and you know much
like myself he has his good days and his
bad days and you know rich yes now that
I'm no longer doing the Olympics I'm not
going to the Super Bowl this may be my
single best ongoing claim to thing broke
one have a pup named after me
well did you were you aware a bob of of
the dog being named bob costas the first
time I became aware was when Brooklyn
was a guest on The Tonight Show when Jay
Leno was still hosting and she dropped
this bit of info on a breathless public
and I happen to be watching are you
offended or are you flattered because it
can go both ways
I mean English bulldogs are not
attractive dogs I am so flattered okay
I've been back if in fact one we're
casting some sort of dog movie the way
they did the cars series oh yeah so I
i'm bob cutlass yeah they tried to miss
the car resemble me in some character
kind of way i don't think one would
choose a bulldog to represent me but
it's okay it's okay it mate it may help
my street cred in some small way yes i
think they are beautiful beautiful dogs
if that makes you feel any better
beautiful dogs they are they are
beautiful dogs they don't seem like a
perfect physical representation of me
but I'll take what UPS you want off for
it's all good okay so it's it's all good
thank you Bob Costas did you know you
had no idea that actor when you were
what when you were informing Jay Leno I
had no idea you were also informing Bob
Costas had no idea and Bob Costas I can
only call you by your first and last
name now so if we meet in person it will
be hello Bob Costas you must know that
I'm ready for it well I would say Bob
Costas stay but we're out of time Bob
well thank you rich Eisen thanks Bob
there you go Wow we've never talked
we've never communicated I wish me now I
would love to say now here's Billy gene
King on the phone right now but yeah now
that didn't happen but could have gone
Bobby Riggs did you guys not think that
I didn't even that sort of feels wrong
but no we didn't even think of that
look hostas feel so right like Bob
Costas erotic actually is that how you
were phrase it Bob Costas is his first
name in Roddick as his last name so we
get calls from the vet and they're like
hello we have Bob Costas erotic ready
for pickup and yeah and I feel like I
love real Bob Costas because I love my
dog so much I feel like I know him you
know a B and I know this sounds he makes
why was your Bob Costas in a cone Oh
oh gosh he's a mess like the real Bob
and I'm kidding he's a mess he had ACL
surgery and then he got a staph
infection and so we get the metal taken
out and that was two days after
Christmas it was dogs of ACLs he's had
two ACL surgeries like what is this he's
a diva
like my husband was a professional
athlete and his like he's never had an
ACL I mean in my Bulldog who like
literally sleeps on a couch all day yes
we should ask Bob how his knees are
doing a lot of fun thanks for coming on
here you bet coming up next
Xavier Rhodes and his dog Deion Sanders
we'll hook those now at Xavier Rhodes in
the Minnesota Vikings and Trace Adkins
the country music star again finery calm
people should go to details to try and
just catalog your online buys and manage
your closet and then grace and Frankie
is there is there like a Grace and
Frankie Christmas party where like
Martin Sheen gets the eggnog and and Sam
Waterston we've had we've had we have
wrap parties okay you know and those
those get kind of fun
do they really yeah okay anytime Jane
Fonda's at a party it's gonna be fun I
would agree with that
any time although it's Sam Waterston I
would just wander walk around just here
that law-and-order thing he's like the
most interesting man in the world like
he should be that guy you know he just
has a swag about him it's like a quiet
swag she sits in a corner and just looks
cool fantastic yeah
so again Oh check out Grace and Frankie
fourth season premieres on Netflix
tomorrow night this is a blast
you bet our number 3 of our show Trace
Adkins also Xavier Rhodes and you at the
phone number 844 204 rich one more hour
to go here on this Thursday edition of
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience